foreign  [Music]  I can hear you being quiet mom  I am  hope I didn't ice your game man  no one my age says those words in that  order  it's just hard to see my little man not  be my little boy all the time  here  you know for years I've been taking care  of this little boy  making sure he is loved  that he feels like he belongs wherever  he wants to be  he wants to go out into the world and do  great big things  not bad kid  and what I worry about most  I love you miles  it was they won't look out for you like  us  miles  wanna get out of here  wherever you go from here you have to  have the promise to take care of that  little boy for me  make sure he never forgets where he came  from  [Music]  and  he never doubts that he's loved  [Music]  and he never lets anyone  tell him that he doesn't belong there  you gotta promise miles  I promise  [Music]  who do you think you are really  we are supposed to be the good guys we  are  [Music]